i'm trying not to compartmentalize i'd
rather the burn be everywhere except
exactly where it's at
i'd love to spread this out a little bit
man but i can't it's getting hotter
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by dustin the diamond poirier
he's the number one ranked ufc
lightweight fresh off his win against
conor mcgregor at ufc 257
he does amazing work with his foundation
the good fight and as fate would have it
he also has a hot sauce pourier's
louisiana style
for my money the best new sauce of the
year dustin poirier welcome to the show
thanks for having me man a long time fan
and uh
spice lover as well how do you think
you'll do today what is your head space
like going into this 10-wing gauntlet
i'm focused i'm prepared i put in the
work
these last 31 years and i think i can do
[Music]
it
let's do it
[Music]
that's good might taste familiar it's in
that louisiana style
right it's got a little vinegar not too
spicy
yep i like it
[Music]
so when ronda rousey was on the show one
of the things i found most fascinating
about our conversation is her profound
understanding of the human body in which
ligaments and joints are most vulnerable
thinking back on your last
fight what is it about the cumulative
effect of calf kicks that makes them so
devastating
i've been on both sides of the calf kick
game and um
it's very painful because the swelling
has nowhere to go
the way your calf is is constructed the
swelling can't
spread throughout the rest of your leg
it stays compartmentalized in the calf
and it affects the nerves in your foot
it's called compartment syndrome you can
actually lose the use of your foot
when i had it done to me in new york a
few years back
i went to the hospital they wanted to
cut me open to relieve the pressure
inside of my leg and uh
it's painful man it's bad stuff what is
the most painful submission technique in
your experience
the most painful i i don't like leg
stuff man heel hooks knee bars
anything with the legs it just feels too
funky for me
[Music]
oh that's good man i like this one yeah
it might be my favorite in the lineup
this year
actually wow
that's good stuff so i noticed that the
first thing that you asked for on your
return home from louisiana from
abu dhabi was king cake and it seems
like the locals really came through
for you for those outside of the bayou
how do you explain king cake and why is
it so popular this time of year
it's always around body broth it's
always around uh
the beginning of the year it's it's king
cake man it's it's a special
it's kind of like a donut a huge donut
cake filled with cream cheese or
chocolate but it's louisiana all the way
man and i knew it was king cake time
and i was out in abu dhabi and i was
just craving food because i was cutting
weight
and i was just thinking about king cakes
and then i know that your new louisiana
style hot sauce it just is the tip of
the iceberg when it comes for your love
of cajun cuisine
does chef poirier have a signature dish
like if you had a cookbook what would be
the meal that's on the front cover
dang dude i got so many i love a good
gumbo man
i love making my own roux and and
sitting in front of a pot with a beer
stirring it and this gumbo seasoning
right now you know it's a little chilly
outside it's perfect time for gumbo
everybody comes over when you cook a
gumbo it brings the family together
and i love that so i would do a good
gumbo
[Music]
slightly bit spicier so i'm a big fan of
your appearances on legendary boxing
trainer teddy atlas's podcast because it
really shows the side of you that's
a student of fighting and at the heart
really just a fan of combat sports
is there a vet who you'd say took you
under their wing or showed you the ropes
when you were first starting out
there's two that come to mind that
really helped me out a lot of my career
is tim crater
louisiana's first jiu jitsu black belt
and uh
another one is the grand master of
thunjitsu eve edwards
of all of your ufc opponents who pound
for pound has the heaviest strikes
conor mcgregor is the heaviest handed
guy i've ever fought
and i knew that going into this last one
so i had a
you know i had a good awareness and i
had that was six years ago but you don't
forget those kind of things
besides connor who's the most savage
trash talker
dude it's got to be chael sonnen when he
was at his at his prime
he could sing running his mouth he was
selling paper views
who would you describe as the most
complete fighter you've ever faced
at the time i would say korean zombie
when i fought him back in
i think 2012 maybe he was probably the
most complete
guy that i've run into uh up to that
point
who's your favorite fighter to watch in
the women's division
amanda nunez i really like watching
amanda nunez
uh pound for pound goat but i gotta give
some respect
uh to my girl joanna she's a beast man
such a savage what's the most unique
octagon entrance you've ever seen
we're talking if you're talking about
the ufc probably tom lawler
uh he's done some crazy stuff but
there's this one guy i've heard about
in new jersey who played the price is
right
theme song and then he was in the
audience
people didn't know stood up and had a
name tag on and
out of the audience to the cage that's
amazing he came back come on down
a little spicier here
[Music]
so when you reach the pinnacle of a
sport like you have
you know there's oftentimes a lot of
folklore surrounding the difficult road
that it took to get there
i've heard you say that some of your
amateur fights
had non-standard rules what did you mean
by that and can you give us an example
i've i've fought amateur fights where
they ask
everybody raise their hand if you want
to be allowed to throw elbows tonight
and it's amateur fighting you shouldn't
be allowed to throw elbows but we're
fighting at a
rodeo arena i mean dude everybody's
coming back to the locker room split
open stitches everywhere
everybody's busted open these kids just
aren't at that level
and they're allowing us to throw elbows
or i've been to events where the same
thing we go to the rules community
and they say a couple of fights fell off
of the car
so these fights are going to be three
minute rounds they're gonna be five
minute rounds so now you're fighting
five minutes
five minute amateur rounds it's crazy
man yeah and you know
and seeing that documentary fight phil
that is one of the scenes that stands
out as you're doing these shows
in rodeo arenas and warming up in the
horse stalls and
you know sometimes i'll talk to
wrestlers about their early years or
comedians about their early years and
mma fighters it's kind of the same
struggle
can you give me one thing that you miss
about those days and then another thing
that you don't miss at all
like one high and one low one high for
sure
is all my family and friends from
louisiana can drive to the event
now i'm fighting across the world and
not too many people can make it i really
miss that having everybody there
one of the things i don't miss is shady
promoters man
there's some slime balls in this
business and you got to chase them for
your money and
checks bounce or you break your hand and
they don't cover the medicals
it's a climbing distance
[Music]
smoky flavor i like that all right
dustin we have a recurring segment on
our show called explain that graham we
do a deep dive on our guests instagram
pull interesting pictures that need more
contacts
i'll show you the picture you just tell
us the bigger story and first things
first
it's you and fellow hot ones alum and
louisiana legend theo vaughn
has hanging out with the rat king
inspired you at all to maybe start your
own podcast or anything like that
it has man it has he came out to south
florida
this last training camp when i was
preparing for conor mcgregor and we did
a podcast like a little makeshift
podcast
inside of a strength and conditioning
facility i was working out at
and i told him dude i would love to
start a podcast and break down fights
and talk about fights and he thought it
was a great idea so yeah he's definitely
inspired me to get behind the mic and
camera and put some content out there
and then on the other side of it i know
that he's been training a little bit
what is the rat king's most impressive
quality in the gym
he started training uh when he moved to
nashville and
i know he's doing jiu jitsu he's doing a
lot of gi jiu jitsu
so i would love to find out actually
all right up next here's a post fight
vibe check
after your win over dan hooker who in
your career when you think back
what has been the worst morning after
bangover
the bangor dude correct
when i fought justin gaichi out in
arizona he partially tore my quad
so i couldn't really walk getting on the
flight i guess the elevation or whatever
made my legs swell so much i couldn't
bend my knee i was just walking around
with my leg was like a big
blinker sausage bro i'm dragging it
around i can't move it it's shiny
it's red that hurt and then
last but not least here you are with a
hell of a plate
how would you describe the significance
of the crawfish boil in acadian culture
this is like doing family reunions every
weekend whenever it's crawfish season
you know everybody comes over everybody
brings something
and we all gather around a table outside
we boil the crawfish pour them over the
table
drink beers tell stories it's just such
a great time and
um things like that is part of the
reason being my wife moved back to
louisiana when my daughter was born
because i could not take that from her
childhood
really strong man
got like a little bitter bite there so
the psychology of fighting is a topic of
endless fascination
can you explain what you mean by finding
the calm and the
chaos because i think for most people
instinct on that kind of confrontation
is almost the exact
opposite you know you hear in your
corner streaming
the crowd's going crazy you see the boss
there
this nicer yeah but
in that moment that's what i enjoy most
about fighting
when i think about fights and stuff it
gives me anxiety i'm like dude this is
crazy but what
i enjoy the most is walking through the
fire and being put in that position
that's where i feel comfortable
the world slows down and nothing else
matters but
that moment and it's a special time it's
the realest thing you can do is
hand-to-hand combat in the moment with
someone trying to take you out
i love it staying on the topic of
athlete psychology you know
according to a 2013 study by psychology
professor michael krauss
fighters who smile and their weigh-in
stare down
are more likely to lose than ones who
don't
how much stock do you put into that
pre-fight
stare-down face-off like does it matter
at all
to me i don't i don't think it does
because everybody's different right
one fighter might be you know covering
something up
trying to put on a front smiling like
he's tough but he's really
terrified scared out of his mind one guy
might be really smiling because he
loves the chaos it's hard to tell man i
don't take anything from those
stereotypes
who's the craftiest fighter you've ever
faced when it comes to the dark arts of
playing mind games
conor mcgregor the first time i fought
him 100
no doubt about it the art of war was on
full display
he uh he might have beat me before the
fight started man
talked about louisiana talked about my
family talked about
my skill set whatever he could say i was
a young fighter at the time and i just
thought about everything he said too
much then i would read comments and i
would read articles of what
critics and media are saying and stuff
like that and as i matured in the sport
i realized i just gotta focus on what i
can control
[Music]
let's dive in man let's dive in
[Music]
oh yeah immediately
[Music]
i'm going in again there you go there
you go
yeah this is definitely a step up big
gun
wait till you try the next one
i have before
i won't mention any names because it's
probably beneath you to address it in
any specific way but i
am curious about your thoughts when it
comes to these youtuber boxing matches
there does seem to be two schools of
thought you know
those who think that the excitement
around these events is good for the
sport
and then the other school of thought
being that this is a total embarrassment
to boxing
where do you fall on that spectrum right
if you're selling pay-per-views
it's entertainment but at the same time
this one's hot man yeah i think i poured
too much on this one
it looks like it i know the instructions
told me to measure i did not i'm gonna
be honest
if you're selling paper abuse and you're
in the business of making money it's
entertainment i understand that so i
know why these guys are getting pushed
and all this stuff
but if you're a true boxing fan
i see on that side as well why you don't
want you
to be representing a sport that you love
or
the the casual fans out there when they
talk about combat sports you don't want
them to think of
somebody who's misrepresenting um
people who work their whole entire lives
to master a craft that
very few do you know um
but it's business i understand i
understand what's going on
when you see like internet clout
monsters cutting these wwe style
promos against like actual elite
professional
fighters does that cross a line to you
or is that just something that goes with
the territory these days
it crosses the line to me because i'm
one of these guys who can really scrap
um i i i wish that these guys would get
the fights that they're calling for
and get in there with real opponents and
then we see
you know see who's talking after
[Music]
let's go man i'm feeling it i'm feeling
it
[Music]
oh man right away
right away
[Music]
i got some milk over here but i'm not
touching it dude
do you still watch food network when
you're cutting that sounds like torture
yes i do i went on a marathon of guys
grocery games
training camp i'll probably watch three
seasons
i've heard that you are trying to go
after your own food show do you have an
elevator pitch while you die on the bomb
because you know when you're ready to go
you might have a home here at first we
feast i got it here
food fight with dustin poirier
we go to different cities i check out a
couple local gyms
i train with the guys there then we go
to local uh restaurants i
get in the kitchen cook a little bit
hear about their story
food fight diamante boom
i'm sold schoenberger order the run 20
episodes out the game with the snap
my eyes watering i'm starting to sweat
i'm trying not to compartmentalize i'd
rather burn be everywhere except exactly
where it's at
i'd love to spread this out a little bit
man but i can't it's getting hotter
i'm trying my best to be tough right now
man
[Music]
i don't even taste the flavor it's just
burned the flavor is burnt
right just straight fire so i know that
one of the ways that you used to unwind
between
fights back in the day was you joined a
bowling league in your native louisiana
if you don't mind me asking what's your
average score i was averaging about 165.
i i know it's not the best but it's an
average that's my average
you know the camaraderie of just a bunch
of guys
that work all week and can't wait to be
off of work finally go to the bowl alley
get some beers down
knock some pins down and have some fun
man it's just uh
good friendship good camaraderie kind of
the same thing that i i started going to
jiu jitsu gyms for
obviously to learn how to fight and get
better but then i realized that
i enjoy being around these guys you know
when i'm not choking them
we have good conversation
[Music]
let's go man do i have to dab it
oh you know what i like that because you
know the show you know usually on these
uh
on these quarantine episodes i hold off
because it's so clumsy to try to do it
and everybody's already over saucing but
but dustin since you know the show let's
do it bringing it back
don't shorten john do not shorten this
experience
i would never i would never this is the
last dab we call it the last dab because
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last one
you don't have to if you don't want to
dustin cheers what a run
[Music]
oh yeah
deep extremely peppery through the
through the nostrils it burns
[Music]
and instantly my cheeks start sweating
so here we are at the end of our ten
round bout against the wings of
death and there's only one obstacle left
in the way before the final bell
you know i'm so proud of you making this
hot sauce that is so distinctly you
in the louisiana style and even working
with heartbeat which is one of the great
makers so now that you have a sauce
that's distinctly you
i want to play a hot sauce name
association game
well i'll call out a couple of these
bottles and you just tell me
the first fighter it reminds you of okay
a mild sauce like the classic the first
one that we tried
the mouth sauce like a classic uh a
classic sauce is one you can use every
day
frankie edgar is a fighters fighter
could always trust him
trust on him what about this seven spot
the torchbearer honey badger
the honey badger a buddy of mine
named jake hume the honey badger
actually unpredictable and wild man just
like this
sauce to bomb beyond insanity
the bomb beyond insanity mike perry
because he's insane
[Music]
and then finally the one we just had
last dab apollo
[Music]
last ab apollo let's go with conor
mcgregor
this is that one hitter quitter all you
need is one drop
put the hot one strap on dustin poirier
taking on
the wings of death and living to tell
the tale and now there's nothing left to
do
but roll out the red carpet for you my
friend this camera
that camera let the people know what you
have going on in your life
i have the good fight
checking out at thegoodbyegroup.com
we're currently
crowdfunding for the project learn
initiative with the boys and girls club
we're doing some big things in louisiana
and across the world
and also fourier's louisiana style hot
sauce
it's great it's true to a louisiana hot
sauce but there's layers of flavor
you gotta check it out great job dustin
great job
i'm hurting man i'm hurting over here
it's about
how i thought it would be at the
beginning
smooth sailing but when we get here this
area
if you're not careful with this with the
dousing of the sauce you're gonna pay
for it and that's where that's where i'm
paying for it
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is sean evans checking in to say thank
you so much for watching today's episode
if you enjoyed it maybe like it maybe
maybe you throw us a subscribe even
if you're feeling generous and as long
as you keep watching
[ __ ] it i'll keep eating